pourquoi vous portez toujours l'équipe à
qui passaient symbole d'humilité et
c'est là pour rappeler à l'homme qu'il a
toujours quelque chose au dessus de sa
tête
donc c'est avant tout une forme
d'humilité par rapport au monde dans
lequel on est par rapport aux créateurs
qui au dessus de nous et dont on doit se
rappeler qu'il est là vous n'avez pas
droit de plonger de coquillages
crustacés
l'idée au départ c'est quand on parle
des mammifères ces ruminants aux sabots
fendus qui peut être mangé quand on
parle des poissons c'est ce qu'ils ont
des écailles et des nageoires
quand on parle des vols de volatiles
c'est ce qu'ils vont être plutôt des
animaux de basse-cour donc il ya plein
d'animaux qui sont autorisés plein
d'animaux qui sont interdits c'est pas
juste le port par exemple ou les fruits
de mer ça fait partie des interdits
alimentaires qui sont énoncés dans la
torah fond sa place dans un rapport aux
choses très différents qui fait qu' on
introduit de la pensée on introduit la
verticalité on introduit la spiritualité
dans un acte qui pourrait être considéré
comme quelque chose tout à fait normale
tout à fait évident ce que le vivent
mangent végétal se nourrit de la terre
les animaux vont manger les hommes
mangent aussi donc à quelque chose je
dirais qui est de l'ordre du réflexe qui
est de l'ordre du naturel
on va chercher à casser ça on va se dire
l'homme c'est pas juste une bête qui se
nourrit c'est quelqu'un qui va faire un
truc qui va introduire de la pensée de
la réflexion dans les actes du quotidien
pourquoi l'arrière-plan à mélanger le
lait la viande
là encore c'est un interdit biblique et
ya l'idée que la viande regard en elle
comme principe de mort dans le lait
c'est ce qui va nourrir les animaux ce
qui va nourrir les jeunes lettre est un
principe de vie et l idée là encore dans
son alimentation
on va établir une différence stricte en
trop ce qui est vivant et ce qui est
mort vive ans fait partie de la vie vie
heureusement ce fait partie de la vie
n'aurait pas mélanger les deux
donc vous ne pouvez pas manger des
hamburgers non pourquoi on ne peut pas
toucher d'objets électrique pendant
shabbat shabbat jour de repos
c'est un jour pendant lequel on est
supposé ne pas faire ce qui est
considéré comme un travail ne pas faire
ce qui est considéré comme faisant
partie du quotidien c'est vraiment un
jour pendant lequel on se coupe du reste
de nos habitudes et faire un feu en
réalité c'est ce qui est interdit et ce
qui découle du feu sait utiliser
l'électricité
donc pendant shabbat on n'utilise pas
l'électricité c'est une manière
sanctifié ce jour et se concentrer sur
d'autres choses qui n'ont pas à voir
avec le quotidien et pas l'idée tout le
monde le fait c'est bien personne le
fait c'est mal vieilli a ses règles et
on espère que chacun à son niveau est
capable de progresser pour le faire est
ce que vous regardez les séries moins
souvent surtout depuis le premier
confinement quelle est la dernière série
que vous avez bin jawad chez moi je
connais pas ce mot c'est à dire regarder
en intégralité toutes les saisons en une
traite mois jusqu'au boutiste donc même
une série de nuls à partir du moi j'ai
regardé le premier numéro jeu jusqu'au
bout
mais j'essaie pour sa de regarder les
séries plutôt pas mal
j'ai regardé house of cards j'ai regardé
au crown
j'ai regardé d'euros des légendes
barreaux noirs blancs ce moment je
regarde une série israélienne s'appelle
sheets elle l'avait regardé fao da aussi
en syrie israélienne est vrai que vous
ne pouvez pas serrer la main à une femme
autre que la vôtre alors les différents
courants du judaïsme et selon le courant
auquel vous vous adressez vous allez
avoir différents types d'attitudes dans
les relations entre les sexes par
exemple moi j'appartiens à un courant
qui est considéré comme plus
progressistes et on n'a pas de
distinction comme celle là entre hommes
et femmes on peut serrer la main de tout
le monde si vous avez une relation
adultère une circonstance comme ça j'ai
un peu plus peur de ma femme que de dieu
comment on devient rabin en suivant
toute une
série d'études série de cours dans
lesquels on apprend la torah le talmud
commentaires la gestion de la vie
communautaire
la loi juive et ensuite on trouve une
synagogue qui veut bien de nous
habituellement ces études qui tourne
autour de 5 ans que vous avez sur la
religion avec vos amis non croyants dans
le judaïsme s'intéressent pas forcément
à la question de la croyance pas
déterminant savoir qui est ce qu'ils
croient qu est-ce qui croient pas parce
que on est dans quelque chose du ressort
de l'ain team
on est dans quelque chose qui évolue
tout au long d'une vie qui évoluent en
fonction des différentes situations
j'y reste est beaucoup plus intéressant
c'est le cfai de savoir qui fait quoi
qui est-ce qui a un comportement digne
qu'est-ce qui est un comportement pas
trop horrible et qui est capable de se
comporter d'agir avec justice
[Musique]